the show opens on a Peruvian Beach where
a fisherman is preparing to go out into
the sea in order to catch his trade upon
sailing at a distance he throws down the
net but for some reason it is pulled
down causing him to be dragged into the
water soon after the net settles down at
the seafloor and gets stuck in the
pointy crevasses of rocks as a result he
dives into the water to untangle it but
before he can do so he is attacked by a
swarm of fish that kills him instantly
the scene then cuts to the Shetland
Island in Scotland where we are
introduced to a marine biologist named
Charlie vagna she works for the
Institute of Marine Biology whose
headquarters is located in Kel Germany
however she is currently stationed in
this island due to some mistakes she
made with the auvs in the past the auvs
are autonomous underwater vehicles that
are used for surveillance purposes and
the identification of new forms of
marine life one day Charlie receives a
call from Raheem her cooworker in K he
instructs her to accurately map a seabed
section by running the auv 25 m above
the sea floor he reveals that their
program head Professor Layman is
displeased with Charlie's past mistakes
so she now wants her to carry out the
work correctly their conversation is
abruptly interrupted when Charlie
notices a signal on her computer screen
alerting that one of the auvs has
stopped working as a result she hangs up
the call and goes out to the sea to
inspect upon diving into to the water
she finds something stuck in the chains
of a buoy as she proceeds to untangle it
she senses something around her which
scares her she then quickly floats back
to the surface only to discover that her
boat is drifting away from her but
fortunately Charlie manages to swim
towards it and get a hold allowing her
to breathe a sigh of relief did she get
the auv though did she do her damn job
this time we then cut to Canada where
the Vancouver Marine Institute discovers
a washed up Orca at the beach it has has
several bruises on its body that
indicates human intervention to delve
into the incident two Institute members
named Leon and Jack visit a local
fisherman named kit at Murray Cove the
fisherman reveals that the Orca
uncharacteristically attacked their boat
earlier that morning they tried to avoid
it but when it kept on attacking they
had no other choice but to fight back
that's a bunch of crap kit orcas are
sweethearts meanwhile Jess and Thomas
from The Institute of Marine Biology
travel to sh to help Charlie in
repairing the damaged auv Thomas is
surprised to discover a damaged circuit
board which raises his suspicion towards
Charlie but she swears that she didn't
do anything that evening Charlie visits
a local bar seeking relaxation there
she's approached by a fisherman named
Douglas McKinnon the most fisherman name
of them all who strikes up a
conversation with her not knowing if his
profession Charlie regards this place as
overfished but despite this initial
offense the two get along long and they
end up spending the night together back
in Canada Leon is concerned by the delay
in the migrating whales because they
have never been this late to arrive this
rare phenomenon has started to affect
the local Marine tourism in Canada
Leon's girlfriend Lizzy runs a small
boat that takes Spectators to see these
whales in open Waters however she isn't
getting enough customers due to the lack
of well whales when they meet Lizzie
confides in Leon that she might even be
forced to sell the boat if this
situation persists the following day
Charlie prepares to deploy the auv in
the water and she's accompanied by
Douglas as they sail in the water they
spot numerous pieces of methane hydrate
on the surface this appears to be
unusual so Charlie records the site in
her phone later in the evening she stays
on a conference call with Raheem Jess
and Professor Layman after a brief
discussion of the methane hydrates the
professor reprimands Charlie for taking
unauthorized non-employee Personnel on
the boat emphasizing the institute's
potential life liability in case of an
accident I don't care if you like to
touch the fisherman's penis yeah you
keep him off the boat in the next scene
we are introduced to Alicia Delaware an
Italian American reporter who works for
the world Oceanic Congress she is
currently in Canada to cover the news of
the migrating Wales during her meeting
with Jack they exchange information
about each other Jack reveals he was in
charge of training dolphins in the Navy
to clear underwater mines in the Persian
Gulf as the Dolphins retired the Navy
put them in the entrapments and wait
needed for them to die Jack couldn't let
that happen so he generously released
them in open Waters however this
resulted in his expulsion from the Navy
the next day Leon detects underwater
signals indicating the whale's arrival
however he's taken aback as they all are
appearing at the same time as soon as
Lizzie gets this news she takes a boat
full of people out to the ocean sensing
something a Miss Leon sets out to the
Sea for a closer inspection while on the
water a whale surfaces for moments locks
eyes with him and swims away leyon then
uses his binoculars and discovers that
it's actually going towards lizz's boat
moreover he hears the sound of multiple
orcas advancing toward the boat at a
great speed in a panicked State he
attempts to contact lizz's boat but gets
no response hence he races to save his
girlfriend initially a whale performs a
few flips exciting The Spectators but
soon after it lands directly onto the
boat splitting it in half and plunging
the occupants into the water I just went
whale watching last week I'm so glad I
didn't read this first following this
the apex predators begin praying on the
passengers one after another Leon
arrives at the same time and starts
pulling the people aboard but as he
extends his hand to save Lizzy at last
one of the orcas drags her down leaving
him devastated we got your
girlfriend the scene then shifts to
France where we see a restaurant Chef
buying some fresh seafood from the
market it's probably Lizzy after
shopping he heads back to the restaurant
and starts preparing lobsters for that
night during the process one of the
lobsters squirts white liquid onto his
face I know you're expecting me to make
a joke here but I won't this disgusts
the chef who then orders his subordinate
G to clean up the mess after some time
the chef starts feeling unwell and steps
outside for fresh air his condition
deteriorates as he ultimately collapses
to the ground and vomits blood before
dying Gilberto who is also exposed to
the poisonous Lobster starts feeling
uneasy and is admitted to the hospital
there two French doctors Sophia and
Cecil attend to Gilberto and are
surprised by the rapid onset of symptoms
Cecil walks back to her cabin and is
shocked to find her children there turns
out that the kids took the Train by
themselves from Brussels and didn't
inform either parent before coming to
France Cecil then immediately calls her
husband because it's his turn to babysit
however she learns that he's unavailable
right now on the other hand a charter
ship which is hired by an organization
called hovestad Energy sails in the
Norwegian sea a professor named seur
from tonim University is summoned to
address a peculiar species of ice worm
they found in the sea Flor seur is
instantly alarmed and intrigued by the
rapid pace of its replication upon
further examination he discovers that
these worms have unusually long and
sharp claws at the top of their heads he
asks Tina who is the compliance officer
for hovstad to refer to the experts but
she expresses her wish to continue with
seor it appears that the two have some
romantic past but neither wants to
acknowledge the tension between them
seur is also apprehensive to help and
see his name as one of the experts
consulted because he knows about hov's
Shady history of bending the rules
around environmental clearances later on
seur and Tina visit Professor Layman's
lab to discuss the same species like the
other sea creatures the worms exhibit a
suicidal tendency continuously
penetrating the ice on the seafloor even
though there isn't anything for them to
feed on afterwards the two have a
meeting with hovestad members Aaron and
Erica who are worried that the new
discovery might hinder their operations
of retrieving gas and oil reserves both
seagler and Tina advocate for
environmentally responsible practices
volunteering to collect more samples and
assess the extent of the worms spread
after meeting seor offers Tina a ride
but he he kind of sad to see her new
boyfriend waiting outside oh he is the
real sewor meanwhile in France Cecil
continues to investigate the poison case
through questioning a restaurant
employee she discovers that Elena
another staff member was the one to
dispose of the toxic Lobster into the
garbage following this Cecil visits
Elena's residence only to learn that she
has already passed away simultaneously
at the hospital Gilberto suffers a
massive heart attack and dies on on a
different front Leon visits the Port
Authorities office to talk to Captain
Nakamura the captain shares details of
another whale attack incident involving
a ship called barrier Queen Leon wonders
why these whales are showing aggressive
behavior as they typically only attack
to protect their babies elsewhere seur
Tina and other hovestad members carry
out a second exploration of the sea as
they deploy their device into the water
it is unexpectedly pulled into the sea
floor almost drowning the entire ship
after afterwards Seer and Tina pay a
visit to Layman who shows them how the
bacteria mat is also eating its way
through the ice according to her these
bacteria can go to the bottom of the
seabed which would be disastrous for
marine life later that day Tina invites
seora to come with her to an energy
council meeting she wants to ascertain
if the worms have been found by others
or not seur is initially reluctant due
to his tight schedule but she manages to
convince him to make a short trip in the
next scene Jess and Thomas are are
working on their ship Juno in the open
sea suddenly their ship starts shaking
and the radar signals alarmingly the
workers try to save themselves but to no
avail as the entire ship is sunk this
news soon reaches raheem's ears who then
relays it to Charlie leaving her in
shock back in France Cecile examines
blood work from the chef Gilberto and
Elena leading to a startling Revelation
the infections are caused by vibrio vus
a bacterium that produces toxins upon
contact with blood furthermore the
vibrio consumes human blood at an
astonishing rate Sophia who has been
listening to Cecil informs her that more
people have been reported with the
infection up the coast Cecil finally
realizes the infection is spreading due
to the disposed Lobster that has
contaminated the water system concerned
for her children's safety amidst Rising
infection cases she decides to send them
to her father at their vacation house in
cor bigy Place sounds goofy as
on the other hand Leon who wants to get
to the bottom of the attacks by the
whales gains permission to carry out a
postmortem on the dead Orca upon doing
so he finds a strange fungus-like clot
growing in the Dead orca's brain tissue
after some time he also recognizes that
all the attacks and abnormalities until
now have been in the migration path of
the whales upon learning of all this he
decides to take matters in his own hands
and get to the bottom of this conundrum
following this Leon along with Jack and
Alicia sails to the middle of the ocean
where they've tracked the sleeping
whales Leon Dives down and places a
camera on one of their backs as soon as
he does so the whales abruptly awaken
and start behaving aggressively but
fortunately Leon manages to resurface
just in time and the trio narrowly
escapes meanwhile seor has a meeting
with Sato an operator from mune
Enterprises to exchange his findings on
Ice worms with something in return as
they talk seor suggests that the ongoing
situation can pose a problem for mune
Enterprises given their interests in the
shipping business in response Sato asks
him for some time to think and discuss
this matter with his Superior before
closing the deal after this brief
meeting seur goes to meet Tina and
confides in her about the meeting
hearing this she believes that mune will
leverage their finding to prop up his
efforts in cleaning the ocean through
his other scientific Endeavors while
talking seor begins to get overwhelmed
by past memories and struggles to focus
on work rated matters as a result he
starts flirting with Tina despite
knowing that she has a new boyfriend
initially she tries to resist but ends
up giving into her feelings and sigur's
raw Norwegian charm and cheats on her
partner the following day seur receives
a call from satto who shares their
findings from the South China Sea and
the non Kai trough importantly sat
reveals that hovestad doesn't have an
exploration license and suggests that
Tina may have misled seor he also
forwards a video that proves hoad's ill
intentions from the past despite this
Revelation seor doesn't confront Tina
directly probably because he likes her
bum a lot instead he stresses the
urgency of going back to the Sea and
surveying other areas to assess the
extent of the ice worm's impact he
claims that the worms situated on slopes
have the potential to disrupt the Marine
ecosystem elsewhere Charlie returns to
the Institute of Marine Biology to learn
what happened to Juno not long after
Professor Layman arrives with video
footage depicting the sinking of the
Juno together with Charlie and Raheem
they start reviewing the footage holy
crap it was the avatars in the meantime
Leon gets to know that the whale has
removed his camera he later retrieves it
from the middle of the ocean he then
takes it to the lab where Jack and
Delicia join him in watching it as the
video plays we see the whales diving
deeper than usual toward a mysterious
illuminated entity in the depths of the
ocean
something which is also seen clasping
onto the drowned Juno subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching